I was lucky enough to direct a film
called Toy Story I was lucky because of
amazing people I worked with to help
create that film was the first computer
animated feature film ever made and I
was given by the Academy a special
achievement Oscar for leading the Toy
Story team to the first ever computer
animated feature film and that was
pretty exciting to get that call that
year that the Board of Governors had
voted me that special Oscar and so it
was exciting it was so exciting to go to
the Academy Awards that year knowing I
had won but that year also it was very
special because Toy Story was nominated
for Best Original Screenplay and was the
first animated film ever in the history
of the Oscars to be nominated for a
writing award and so that was extremely
special to us so that was you know
winning an award is great but being
nominated also is a very very special
achievement it's an award into itself
and that is something you know forever
in my career will be one of the things
that I'm most proud of is being
nominated for that award